mic sous-chefs key is set to join us I
like the answer he had the other night
after beating North Carolina State and I
think he was reacting to social media
what people fans have been saying by the
way look at what's happened with
Kentucky social media roughed up
Kentucky last night after they lost to
Tennessee and I think Coach K was
responding to that when he had this
great answer would you lose then you've
lost though the world is going to end
and a lot of pressures put on you know
even social media like it's amazing what
people put out yeah really if you're our
fans don't do that you know come on man
these kids are 18 and 19 years old I
mean you can question my coaching and
what the hell and then when you do
question it by the way just come into
Cameron and look up in the ceiling yeah
alright and then then find out if you
should question that you know but don't
don't do anything with our players
yeah just support them that's Coach K he
didn't go scoreboard he went rafters
there and Coach K joining us I liked it
man you're wrong you're becoming
irascible here well I you know my job is
not to have my players affected you know
and I don't want them answering people
and the other thing insane saying that
it it moves it to me and so you're not
then talk about me don't talk about them
and you know it was the right thing to
do whether the right words or whatever
the you all can judge that I loved it I
loved it but I I just you know we're so
impatient nowadays coach where we don't
take in sort of the volume of what has
been accomplished is what's wrong with
us now like it's you know there's this
panic that sense in right no there is
and you know like I think part of it too
and although I think if this has been
good for college basketball a couple a
few years ago people you know we're
saying you know the regular season
doesn't mean much
you know it's but you know now we start
seating people in December and people
around the bubble you know and it's like
the day-to-day thing you know and it's
created more interest but also it
creates judgment on that specific day
instead of your body of work or people
are improving or people are going
through a little bit of tough time and
by the way in order to improve sometimes
you have to most of the time you have to
go through a tough time and it's part of
a whole season but everyone in our sport
now is being judged by the bubble where
you're seated what wine you drop to are
you in out are you close to being out
are you the next for the final eight or
we have so many things that you can be
well also the mock drafts for your
players is well no it doesn't say those
are crazy like they change every week
and you know by the way up hardly any of
those are ever correct you know I mean
the what do you think all the GMs are
getting together and saying these are
the guys we're going to draft and you
know and then when you don't get drafted
where you're supposed to then we blame
it on the kid for falling in the draft
and it's just because hey somebody who
is not affiliated with a program or a
Scouter is just a writer who's saying
hey here's my mock draft James Weisman
is going to go number one I'm like okay
yeah you know one of the ball boys is
gonna go like night like I it's hard to
keep up on you 66
yeah it's your but move on Patrick hey
last hey I got a couple week my date and
Flyers are tomorrow they're doing pretty
well there coach yeah you know what
they're they are coached by a heck of a
guy who you know obvious it's all
modern - but he you know sometimes you
get let go and then you like he's grown
so much and he's always been an
outstanding coach but I think he is Rui
showing it man I think he's you know and
is there your number of guys who have
done a great job but you know for
national coach of the year he's got to
be a prime guy for that do you have a
bet who goes farther Dayton or Duke no I
don't you know we're not allowed to bet
I know you you have sports wagers and
things like yes I do show yes I do and
like the only bet i made was that your
show is going to continue for forever
and because it's so damn good and so far
I've won on that bet
yes you have but but when you retire I
retire now don't you I'll retire before
you retire you know make you last
another five years let's not talk about
five years let's just talk about the
fact we got Carolina I guess I just
signed up for five more years coach yeah
well they were smart you want imagine oh
[Laughter]
did you just go to the rafters with me
as well no I didn't perspective I have a
better contract in yeah that's all right
I deserve it yeah you do you deserve a
good one too
you know I'm not I'm not selfish where I
feel I should only get I should only get
and I I want to reward excellence
I want excellence rewarded let's put it
that way I have so many banners I have
to build new rafters here coach yeah but
don't put it like for being in the
tournament no the rest of the banners
are only Championships not that you were
participant do you have ACC co-champs
banner well that's a chance though it's
coach am
yeah Co it's like a code chance it's not
like a true champ there yeah well we
should have had a playoff done right yes
the banner North Carolina coming up this
weekend at Cameron Indoor do you know
what kind of team do you have right now
not completely no how long is it usually
take the whole season I don't think you
ever know completely you yeah
even a veteran team you know there's
always there's there's always something
happening in in development of an
individual an injury you know sometimes
they're in this time of year kid starts
worrying about an older player what
about you know I know March is exciting
but what's happened to me in May and you
know just the things that can happen to
human beings so I think you always are
and they happen more to 18 to 22 year
old kids and I like my team I think my
team has responded well they've they've
really done a good job this year and but
there's a lot more variance because
they're all every one of them is a
developing player they're not they're
not at a level that a Tatum was or
Bagley or corridor Zion or RJ that's not
knocking I'm those kids were just at a
different level and even in in
competitive maturity and we're
developing all that in you know overall
in our kids everyone you know they're
twenty four and six I mean they they've
been terrific talking to Mike sous-chefs
key his team is 12th in the nation they
got North Carolina coming up this
weekend at Cameron Indoor Zion went on
JJ Redax podcast a while back and said
that he really he wanted to stay another
year at Duke like you
you told him to go like did you have
that conversation where he'd said coach
I want to stay or can I stay no no I I
always die in loves loves Duke and Sian
loved every everything about the guys
the you know college life too you know
what one of the things it you know one I
remember Kobe telling me and my wife you
know he never went to college it's you
know I I wish that I had gone and then
obviously I couldn't go because that's
where you make friends you know and and
Zion has a lot of friends here and and
you would like yeah have loved to have
made more friends but obviously
economically and the fact that you only
have a certain lifespan as a as a pro
player you got to go when you have to go
but you know he was back during the
all-star break for about four days and
worked out you know if you it's a safe
place it's a home that's what we want
these guys to understand and when they
come back no one wants anything from you
just be you and shell out and work out
and that's what he's saying and you know
he doesn't live that life any anywhere
else
we had Kobe on a few times and I
remember it might have been 10 years ago
where I said if you had gone to college
where would you have gone he said old
Duke did you recruit him yeah we did he
never took this it's we knew he's going
to go pro and but not I never saw LeBron
play in high school
and but Kobe I've said this many many
times for many years Kobe was the best
high school player I ever saw and he had
a maturity competitive arrogance to go
along with his talent that was way way
off to
charts even as a high school player when
he walked into a gym even first summer
early game the gym looked around and
said oh Kobe's here and and then he he
did it just yeah
I really the two players that I had
association with and Michael Jordan just
for a brief time with the dream team you
know they they had that that's why I
love the fact that they became friends
and Michael and said that he's like a
little brother and by the way how his
eulogy is his talk at the at that
service for Kobe was unbelievable just
unbelievable but I you know Mike it
almost seemed like he developed that
confidence once he got to the NBA where
as Kobe had it at an early age yeah I
think Kobe had it and maybe but you know
growing up in Italy and being around
older players and that I thought Michael
developed it while he was at North
Carolina and you could see him grow into
that oh you noticed it in college
because I I just never looked at him
that way because it felt like it was
more were these team than Michael and
Michael of course hit the big shot to
win the national yeah but you could I
think he was still developing you know
he was developing that though that's
what I'm you know where and then yeah he
he and Kobe were cut from the same cloth
you know I mean they too are the
incredibly unique athletes and
competitors in any sport and and the
fact that they had that relationship was
some believe on I think it's it you know
through USA Basketball the relationship
that Kobe developed with LeBron would
never have been developed had it not
been for USA basketball and their
ability to play on two teams together
and
when two gold medals they were they were
fantastic together and the the I think
the thing that people don't realize is
just how brilliant Kobe was and so and
cooking LeBron is and they recognized
not just talent they recognized their
energy inner drive but also the fact
that was so damn smart but how do you
coach that that because that's a
different personality that yeah you know
when you see that in in college how do
you take advantage of it and let that
personality be something that's positive
for these players now it's a good
question and what you try to do is not
put a ceiling on it or give it an
opportunity to to you know just like you
would say would you know take whenever
you feel that you can shoot you know
with these got with guys of that caliber
whatever you are thinking say it and
don't think that other guys are thinking
what you're thinking but because they're
not every once in a while they might be
but you know in other words have a voice
you know where you can say what you want
to say whenever you you feel you know
you whenever you feel it and that's all
we did it with the US team and when I
have a I try to get on my team Trey
Jones to do that yeah that's it you know
say what you think at the moment you're
thinking that and everybody will be
better and the guy who'll be the most
who will get better the most is you
because you you'll be in control of your
environment done and when you have a
brilliant player the ability to say
things at the moment you're competing is
much more important than what a coach
says in the moments where you're not
competing you're just preparing or
you're at a timeout when you have a
player that can do that during
competition boy it takes it to level you
have a Magic Johnson you know if guys
there you know
that many but when when you see you know
you see the the physical but it what
they do with their voice is phenomenal
it's just phenomenal are you more likely
to know how many wins you have or how
many losses you have I don't know either
well for the season I know I don't know
this is all time no I don't know you
don't know you don't know I mean I know
we have like over 1100 because someone
said we celebrated 1100 and and I know
when when there's certain so-called
milestones because John Jackson and I
Mike the George and all the people say
you know that was your 1,000th win as a
ranked team as a ranked team or that was
your 500 ACC when you know against ACC
competition and then when I hear that I
said wow that's that's good that's
pretty pretty good you can't that that's
not the thing that you got to be in the
moment you're in I mean and then that
other stuff takes care of itself
well you say we have 1156 wins but you
have 350 losses yeah you yeah yeah I
blame I blame all those losses on you
know you know you have 350 it feels like
we when we win but it's you when you
lose I think coach feels that yeah yeah
yeah you make it more sense no thank you
I thought you were you know not going on
the sword for me but so what do you have
in for lunch today I don't really eat
once I we have a we practice about 1:30
so I have a waiter breath I usually have
two meals during the day I just carry
spy stop by like what are we having
well we can get you stuff yeah what do
you want
we're good you know we aim to please but
if we went out I'm gonna eat with you no
no it's fine I'll find a space like up
in the up
but but if we went to Durham and we went
to dinner where are we going
I'd surprise you what if I had job my
house take it out on my wine cellar I
like that
yes yeah now this is like oh you know
that'll never have okay but I know but
you know no but you know you have like a
two-bedroom bungalow some point we have
real small we don't have like small
houses look like a crazy house but we
have a is it a mansion no it's it's
really what we do have is a great a
great area because we have 14 acres of
land and eight of them are deer fenced
and we do a lot of flowers and their
basketball hoop there cuz I gotta put on
a clinic there is okay and it you can
adjust the height to seven and a half
feet but you're gonna have to get back
up nets if I come to town that's all I'm
gonna say we have changed that I grew up
in the suburbs like you you know we have
chained that we didn't have nets yeah
because all your your rich friends my
rich friends know all we just had rims
and then I hated it cuz every time I'd
swish it then you know did you'd have to
go chase the ball I never touched the
rim I mean really that's what's amazing
about it was swish or an air ball right
yep absolutely absolutely
hey have fun against North Carolina we
do yeah Thank You coach great to talk to
you so that's always good Dan thank you
that's Mike sous chef ski pretty decent
coach you two are so cute yeah we are
yeah
one of these days I'm going down there
going down there I'm just gonna just
walk into practice pick up basketball
and start taking some shots